Barbara Walters died just a few days ago
did you remember that Barbara Walters
was at my wedding to Beth yes she yes
she's at my table I thought about that
uh when I heard the news I always loved
Barbara Walters yeah when we first
started working in Washington I went
from school to practically working in a
Major Market and I was like I'm not
ready for this I can't you know I people
keep offering me these jobs that I am
not ready to handle and I said well
you've got to do this job so who can you
be and I said I'll be Barbara Walters
because she was a groundbreaker and she
was Fearless so I would pretend to be
Barbara Walters while I was sitting
there she was the first woman to
moderate a presidential debate there you
go good evening I'm Barbara Walters
moderator of the last of the debates of
1976 between Gerald R Ford Republican
candidate for president and Jimmy Carter
Democratic candidate for president I
interviewed her a couple of times
Barbara told me about the one celebrity
that made her so excited she had to stop
the interview let me hear that the only
attraction was a flirtation with
Clint Eastwood in which I got so
flustered I on camera stopped the tape
you really were sexually excited by
Clint Eastwood yes I was when you say
sexually excited I'm really excited we
were flirting it's actually excited in
the middle of an interview is a little
hard to be you didn't have sex with him
though
and then she um told us how she created
The View ABC had come to me and said do
you have an idea for a daytime show I
never watched daytime so I didn't really
have an idea but I said I wanted to do a
show and in the back of my mind I had
with different women of different
Generations just talking the way you
would if you were sitting around the way
we are here yeah or at your breakfast
table and this was today it's done all
the time but then that was very new to
take a bunch of women of different ages
different personalities different
political opinions stick them on the air
and say talk Gilda Radner did an
impersonation of her on Saturday Night
Live and it turns out she hated the
impression
and welcome to Baba at watch
we are indeed lucky to have as our guest
tonight the great we respected and
world-renowned creator of shuttle
diplomacy sometimes controversial but to
my mind uh will we regular guy that was
a great that was so good
yeah she she hated it you know what
surprised me when I was reading the
notes was that she really was hurt by
the Gilda Radner impression that Bobby
wall was yeah but you you you were hurt
by Gilda Radner making a fun of you well
what you know Bow Wow
oh Mommy light not and she did lighten
up about it because after Gilda died
uh Barbara Walters sent her husband Gene
Wilder a note signed Baba Wawa Legend
she will be missed